llegó el espacio de economía en France
24 con nuestra periodista de
especializada Daniela Blandón Daniela
bienvenida Y empezamos hablando del tema
del momento porque parece que a Rusia ya
comenzaron a afectarle las sanciones que
le impuesto oxidante Así es María clara
muy buenas noches pues vemos un repaso
primero esas medidas es que Estados
Unidos Les prohibió a sus entidades
financieras hacer transacciones con el
Banco Central de Rusia y congeló sus
activos en una medida coordinada con la
Unión Europea con Canadá y con Reino
Unido esto con excepción de algunas
transacciones del sector energético que
es tan importante para occidente como
para Rusia las restricciones también se
dirigen contra el Ministerio de finanzas
de Rusia y contra el fondo Nacional de
inversión ruso que es un fondo Estatal
para garantizarles las pensiones a los
ciudadanos de ese país ahora la Casa
Blanca está concentrada en redactar con
sus aliados occidentales en la lista de
bancos que van a hacer excluidos del
sistema de comunicación interbancario
internacional También conocido como
Swift por sus siglas en inglés y que
aislaría aún más a la economía rusa Pues
el kremlin y María clara le cuento que
está invitando a los actores del mercado
extranjero a unirse a un sistema propio
que creó para hacerle competencia
justamente a Swift Pues nosotros
consultamos con
Francisco Joaquín Cortés Quién es doctor
en economía
mi profesor en la universidad
internacional de La Rioja
yo creo que ya Prácticamente la
descontaba Es verdad
que al sistema financiero ruso
ir al Banco Central ruso subiendo el
tipo de descuento al 20% lo cual pone
manifiesto las dificultad económicas que
ya de por sí Rusia tenía grande
dificultad económicas pues se le ha
añadido algo que aunque estaba
descontado por Rusia y por putín
realmente el alcance no no lo esperaba
tanto
le voy a dar algunos datos Y así
llegamos a la conclusión mire Rusia
produce el 10% del petróleo mundial unos
10 millones de los 100 millones de
barriles que se consumen a diario y
suministra el 40% del gas natural en
Europa también es el mayor exportador de
cereales y fertilizantes del mundo y el
primer productor de paladio y de níquel
es así mismo el tercer exportador de
Carbón y acero y el quinto exportador de
madera
Ucrania por parte de Rusia ha provocado
una enorme fuga de capitales para
hacerle frente a esta situación las
autoridades económicas anunciaron una
serie de medidas entre ellas la bolsa
cerró temporalmente después de una caída
abrupta la semana pasada la tasa de
interés se duplicó era casi del 10% a
horas del 20% y también habrá control de
capitales escuchemos al experto
evidentemente
tan extrema que ha experimentado en 30%
el
rublocimiento de la economía rusa
del resto del mundo me refiero de Rusia
pensemos que el Banco Central ruso tiene
reservas fuera de Rusia por
aproximadamente No seas más de 600.000
millones de dólares lo cual y ahora
mismo están están bloqueados lógicamente
eso va a suponer también un impacto y
bueno Y también lo que stm es que si
sigue pues es las medidas grabándose las
medidas pues e incluso podría haber un
cierto
bancario
de sanciones occidentales ya comienza a
tener efecto sobre los ciudadanos no
solamente sobre el kremlin miles de
rusos hacen filas frente a los cajeros
automáticos preocupados de que las
sanciones pudieran provocar escasez de
efectivo a incertidumbre entre ellos
escuchemos algunos
está pagado todos los productos
extranjeros se pagan con tarjeta Me
pregunto cómo nos compraremos trabajo en
central department Store Cómo comprarle
ropa en Italia
las consecuencias
todas las aplicaciones bancarias
tengo que conseguir una tarjeta bancaria
pero ni siquiera recuerdo cómo vivir con
ella
afectados se cuentan Los viajeros que
iban desde y hacia Rusia Qué está
pasando con ellos
sobre sus espacios aéreos y Washington
no descartó una acción similar en
respuesta a la invasión rusa de Ucrania
Rusia prohibió el uso de su espacio
aéreo por parte de aerolíneas de 36
países incluidos los 27 miembros de la
Unión Europea después de que los
ministros del bloque comun yo acordar a
negar la entrada a los aviones rusos
incluidos los jets privados de los
oligarcas de este país pues sin acceso
al espacio aéreo de Rusia muchas
aerolíneas tendrán que desviar los
vuelos hacia el sur y evitar las áreas
de tensión le voy a dar dos ejemplos
Solo este lunes los cambios de ruta
desde Europa significaron en que los
vuelos en el espacio aéreo de kazajistán
se triplicaran
todas estas prohibiciones de occidente
también están afectando a las empresas
privadas qué está pasando pues es la
comisión europea pidió a Google y a
YouTube que suspendan las cuentas de
Rusia today y de spot Nick y otros
medios a fines al kremlin esto para
cumplir con las sanciones que aprobó la
Unión Europea entre ellas el Beto para
que emitan el territorio comunitario
continuando en el plano
noticias de las compañías
alojamiento gratuito a corto plazo para
100,000 refugiados ucranianos de los
500,000 que se estima ha dejado la
guerra hasta el momento la empresa
ofreció su apoyo a los gobiernos de
Polonia de Rumanía de Alemania y de
Hungría Para coordinar justamente estas
estadías Daniela y cuéntanos cuáles son
los indicadores del mes pues María Clara
obviamente están en rojo cerraron en
rojo un mes que fue bastante difícil no
solamente por esta guerra sino también
porque Estados Unidos está presto a
subir las tasas de interés Eso quiere
decir pues que las consecuencias de este
endurecimiento de las acciones han
repercutido en los mercados financieros
al cierro de febrero se cerró su segundo
mes en rojo con pérdidas de más del 3%
como también lo hicieron los otros
indicadores en Wall Street y si hablamos
de fuera de Rusia especialmente en
Europa
por supuesto el precio del petróleo
prende este subió más del 3% en la
jornada del lunes y pasó la Barrera
psicológica de los $100 esto es un
término económico ayer estaba 98 hoy
están $100 estos dos son precios que no
se veían desde hace por lo menos 7 años
en el mundo hay muchas cotizaciones
del Golfo de México y es que esta guerra
en Ucrania ha ocasionado incertidumbre
que ha hecho que el precio que hace un
mes estaba ya alto pues siga aumentando
según nuestra blusa Daniela Por qué
aumentan los precios del combustible
tiene que ver con que en la medida que
varios bancos quedaron por fuera del
sistema de pagos es se ven amenazadas
las exportaciones rusas de petróleo y
como veíamos produce un 10% del crudo
mundial esto quiere decir que menos
oferta y más demanda pues llevan los
precios
y también hay otros factores
decidió salir de sus inversiones en
Rusia en petróleo y gas y este es el
mayor inversionista extranjero en ese
país hay Quienes se atreven a decir que
incluso el precio del petróleo puede
llegar a los 115 por barril Gracias
Daniela
los invitamos a que sigan conectados con
nosotros para más información
[Música]